We saw that fishing with the harvest rate that's equal
to the maximum sustainable yield is pretty dangerous.
Let's try to come up with something that's safer--
for instance, ramping up the harvest rate over the course of time.
We don't harvest during the first four years and after a time of 6 years,
we're not using the maximum sustainable yield but we're using something that's a little smaller
0.8 times the maximum sustainable yield.
The 0.8 would be a safety factor and between 4 years and 6 years, let's have a linear ramp.
Now implement this ramp in the computer model. The forward Euler's method is already in place.
You just have to provide the code that computes the harvest rate, which is used here.